bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct ce matin sur rtl france à partir
du 1er juin le chômage partiel va donc
sera moins pris en charge par le
gouvernement il sera adapté à la reprise
de l'activité économique est ce que cela
vous paraît trop tôt où on ne peut pas
faire autrement
non non c'est beaucoup c'est beaucoup
trop tôt bien évidemment et puis encore
une fois c'est faire prévaloir des
logiques comptables sur la réalité la
réalité du pays la réalité du pays c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il ya deux cent quarante
six mille chômeurs en plus à pôle emploi
qui sont inscrits en catégorie a et que
au delà de ces chiffres
eh bien tous ne sont pas indemnisés donc
nous en tout cas on est en contact avec
on a lancé une campagne de témoignage
on reçoit comme témoignage des
travailleurs privés d'emploi qui ce
genre qui sont aujourd'hui sans aucune
indemnisation
elle il n'est pas du tout acceptable que
l'état fasse augmenter cette misère
sociale en arrêtant le chômage partiel
et en ne mettant pas en place les
protections nécessaires pour les
travailleurs la situation en france
aujourd'hui les chiffres sont dans le
rouge
on l'a très bien compris le plus dur est
ce qu'il est devant nous selon vous le
plus dur il est devant nous et surtout
pour les travailleurs privés d'emploi
parce que les jours d'indemnisation il
commence à défiler qu'après le
confinement pour l'instant on n'a pas du
tout d'indication sur gouvernement pour
dire par exemple est ce que jour dès les
jours d'indemnisation
le gel est ce qu'il a été décomptée ou
non donc ça veut dire qu'après le
confinement il ya des milliers des
milliers de travailleurs privés d'emploi
qui ne pourront pas retrouver un emploi
parce que l'impact économique du
coronavirus sera durable et se
retrouveront sans indemnisation donc
voilà on entend beaucoup un débat autour
du déficit autour de la dette
il faut savoir quand même que l'état il
a mis en place des dispositifs
d'exonérations et d'exemptions des
cotisations sociales supérieures la cgt
nous on a des revendications pour
trouver des nouvelles recettes à
l'unedic notamment que l'état de
catastrophe sanitaire soit décrété par
l'état pour mettre à contribution les
assureurs privés et si ça ne suffit pas
eh bien il faudrait penser à d'autres
mesures comme par exemple socialiser des
dividendes pour trouver des financements
supérieur à la sécurité sociale puisque
c'est un scandale qu jour qu'aujourd'hui
encore des entreprises du cac40 versent
des dividendes à leurs actionnaires
un mot sur les parents aussi qui dont
certains vont devoir à partir du 1er
juin justifier que l'établissement
scolaire de leurs enfants ne soient pas
en mesure de les accueillir sous peine
de ne pas bénéficier du chômage partiel
que pensez vous de ce nouveau mode
d'emploi mais ce sens le chantage la du
gouvernement il est il est proprement
scandaleux vous savez nous la cgt depuis
le depuis le début on dit que la vie des
travailleurs elle est bien supérieure à
celle des profits de quelques
actionnaires et d'autres fonds de
pension aujourd'hui ce qui aurait fallu
mettre en place c'est un confinement est
le retour la reprise en tout cas
l'activité économique elle doit pas se
faire au détriment de la santé des
travailleurs
donc voila nous on reste contre la
reprise des
des écoles et les dispositifs de chômage
partiel doivent accompagner une reprise
quand le climat sera serein pour tout le
monde est ce que fait ce gouvernement
vraiment ça n'incite pas à la confiance
et à la mise en place d'un climat serein
dans le pays et s'agissant du des
secteurs hôtelier de celui de la
restauration également est ce qu est ce
qu il aurait fallu prévoir des mesures
spéciales ou est tout à fait j'ai déjà
dans le dire une le gel du décompte des
jours d'indemnisations versées depuis
depuis le 1er mars
c'est quand même des secteurs qui seront
durablement impacté par le cor 1 à virus
puisque le gouvernement aujourd'hui
d'indics pas vraiment de date précise de
reprise d'activité je pense aussi par
exemple aux intermittents
la ministre du travail refuse de mettre
en place une année blanche voilà il ya
des mesures de justice sociale là qu'il
faut que le gouvernement doit doit
prendre et encore une fois le
gouvernement n'a fait que répondre aux
intérêts des des financiers et à
répondre toujours assez de courses du
profit qui est insupportable et qui fait
aujourd'hui qui remporte en tout cas
avec elle son lot de misères de détresse
sociale
la cgt en tous cas en revendique donc
j'ai dû décompte des jours
d'indemnisations versées et une
ouverture d'urgence à l'indemnisation
chômage pour tous ceux qui n'ont pas
encore aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup pierre garneau dit le
secrétaire général du comité national de
travailleurs privés d'emploi et
précaires merci à vous